hey guys Dennis here and no I'm not
doing the air overview I actually
haven't watched the arrow yet I have it
on my Netflix queue and hopefully I can
get caught up soon and and David and
Mike are doing a good job with that so
we recorded the review and I
accidentally messed up the video so I
still have the audio for it so here's
the review I'm sorry about this but it's
just gonna I just put a pictures of
green arrow but you can still hear the
reviewing next week well it will be back
to normal
sorry about that guys hi everyone I'm
David Griffin and now Michael Medina
bringing this week's episode of arrow
season 2 episode 4 crucible and a huge
reveal last week or the League of
Assassins potentially coming to the show
and obviously Ra's al Ghul I want to
know more about what's gonna have with
that but this week it's all about Black
Canary
now the reveal is finally we can finally
say it's Sara Laurel sister is Black
Canary
yeah and if you're like you know myself
and David who didn't stay away from
certain websites much [ __ ] much of the
prize but I mean for those that did stay
away from it I mean that's huge yeah you
know what I mean cuz like I know you and
I are talking about how like I just
assumed it would have been Laurel so the
fact that it wasn't you know her sister
was interesting no coming back from the
dead it was it the Lazarus Pit right no
Rachel cool who knows exactly what it is
right you know saying the comments
letter you were leaving I missed a lot
of this stuff last week about the Amazo
crate in the shipping Lincoln you'll
miss it right so we got to go on the
ship and see what was box that wasn't my
one thing with last week's episode I
loved it but the thought is moving
around too much between yeah present day
and what's going on back on the island
so on the ship we see this guy who's
looking for these bones in the grave and
are they you know misshapen or something
it would assume is he looking for a
Zuri's but he's looking for Raja Bullett
II buried there maybe is he or walking
around on me maybe soon I have to tie it
right League of assassin eyes you know
what I mean yeah I just thought it was
really interesting too it's really cool
the way like the build-up to like the
the just what heat would happen on that
bow and then what it ultimately leads to
later on which we can get to a little
later on in the review but although I
thought this was a very solid episode I
thought it started off kind of slow
yeah dannis
like they got what you know the real
Sarah yeah as black canary I just
thought it really picked up and stuff
that was the mayor yeah episode where
okay kind of I mean the other guys would
like the hats you got a little better :
yeah you know and you know we also got a
nice little reveal later another villain
who is really excited it's gonna say
this because I know we're talking about
this show you know I think he would talk
about arrow every we'd talk about Marvel
agents of shield which took a break this
week us we're not talking about it this
week but I mean I think DC has the
advantage and it's a good in too bad
DC doesn't have a very good universe
moving in Reverse Kalon they don't have
a lot of movies being made right now
they don't have to worry about messing
up continuity because which is you know
for us I guess we'd like to see more
movies but because of that we get to see
Black Canary it just allows them free
rein to open up the universe in stage I
love and you know we see a little bit
more of you know brother blood you know
who and almost we thought was scarecrow
look a little scary okay and that
exactly right not the first time I saw
him but then I was like alright
it's got anybody I didn't say it's about
time cuz I was just like waiting like
halfway through like wouldn't we
actually gonna see little bubbles so
looking forward to that so we get that
reveal at the end and stuff and that was
really cool right you know and then we
also hear there's a Oliver makes a
reference to how he did see Sarah on the
island at one point so he knew that she
was alive but didn't quite reveal to
like digs and in Felicity how he had
seen and what had happened there but we
get that review stored for people
absolutely you assume that's what's
gonna end up happening with that you
know so something went down in that
island between the two of them and stuff
and something you know forced them to
keep that privacy I like how he hinted
of course we're not to get any answers
is gonna be developed over the season
but it's like so what happened to Slade
I mean they just like he of course
changes the subject like whatever -
Deathstroke like you know men yuba
Natalie where where is he and because we
don't know I mean like I want to see him
in present-day I hope he doesn't die on
the island we finally know they gotta
build up to that right you gotta like
fleshed out his back right because I
mean right now he's he's gonna worry
that jewelry don't worry so yeah he's
not really good guy right but he's not a
bad guy
it's right you can see you can tell he's
I guess he's gonna train I don't know
what not but you got
see that transition you know to
ultimately makes them that badass yeah
and then looking of course at laurels
having some tough times drink with the
world drug she's popping pills and
drinking wine and it's not like say I'm
gonna die the episode before anything as
you came to the realization that it's
her well she she shouldn't blame herself
but you thinks it's her fault that Tommy
died but so she's just going off of me
that's quite as I'm dealing with alright
I think that's what arrow does there
does a great job of balancing I just a
little drama
there's also comedy I mean they mix
everything into the same it never takes
itself too seriously which I think makes
such a good show like I know Hugh an
hour talking with us we kind of like to
see Diggle do a little bit more yeah
absolutely I feel like he's always there
he's played a pretty major role in like
Oliver's you know a little universe
there so I'd like to see him go out a
little bit more um one of the things I
really love about this season so far and
I think it's something you know arrow
typically does pretty well I feel like
they did a good job of moving the season
around they're telling a story and stuff
and not just you know if I could said at
the start of the episode I thought it
was gonna be kind of a just a filler
episode it seemed like it was moving
along a little slower [ __ ] a 22-episode
season that's gonna happen but I think
arrow more than most does a good job of
making those 20 episodes count for sure
apps can sit with every show that comes
up especially with this particular
season with everybody coming out we
still have a flash coming up yeah we
have Black Canary we got a little
glimpse of brother blood I mean who else
are we gonna see this year and it's
because of DC's crippled Cinematic
Universe which I'm kind of thankful for
because the show is so good like see ya
movies but it helps we get to see more
character so what the one story I
thought it wasn't bad was just maybe a
little weaker than the rest is the whole
thing with Roy and sin I didn't I don't
get their connection so quickly yeah I
mean I'm glad Roy's a good kid and he
misses a girl by the hospital but a
hospital bed but I don't get why so like
it's almost like his sister was dying or
something like that yeah he did seem to
get him a little involved I do like the
way they're showing him slowly making
progress trying to do right being a good
guy but it did seem like he was just
like rushing to say but maybe that's a
good thing maybe that's what we need to
say to see you know that ultimate
transformation and becoming his Oliver
sidekick possibly I'd imagine you'd have
to be right you know before you know we
end this we have of course mentioned
Summer Glau
mmm lovely summer table I think she's
gonna be a slow build but I did like the
scenes yeah very much a badass
check which I thought was kind of funny
right like I'm your superior so I think
it's gonna be good so we know next
week's episode is actually called League
of Assassins yes they're going all out
for this they're going with so I mean I
want to know like one here I know you
guys are probably looking closely what
are our speculations you know please
share with us like what do you think
we're gonna see amazed oh I don't mean
that's too far I was just a little I
probably like fans I know what's gonna
happen but like you know what's in what
are they shooting up with what are they
getting shot up with it uh you know
brother blood did yeah yeah exactly is
it something from a Lazarus Pit you know
I don't know so there's a lot of stuff
coming up so that's our review for this
week's episode of arrow as always new
come chat with us on the website I think
you're calm there's no check out our
videos right here I think you're a pro
we're also on Twitter as well I was
gonna chat with us at think here's like
a Dennis Michael and I about anything I
think you're related TV shows movies
whatever you're checking out personally
I'm at Griffin de now I'm at mr. Michael
Alexis we also have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero fan
so be sure to spread the word like you
know comment you know subscribe thumbs
up everything you know helps out a lot
so really appreciate that talk to you
guys later
you